juste un petit mot à tous j'imagine
qu'il ya ici beaucoup de militants
d'ile-de-france j'imagine qu'il ya aussi
des militants qui viennent de partout en
france et moi ce que je veux vous dire
aujourd'hui ce matin c'est que les
régionales les élections régionales qui
auront lieu en décembre que le
gouvernement a sciemment mis en décembre
pour que personne n'aille voter pour
parce que personne c'est qu'il y à des
élections en décembre parce qu'on a plus
voté en décembre depuis 1965
donc le sujet c'est que ces élections
régionales sont une étape clé sur le
chemin de l'alternance
vous connaissez la devise vous
connaissez la devise de la coupe du
monde
et un et deux et trois zéro alors et 1
c'était les municipales et de les
départementales et 3 les régionales et
je vous demande d'applaudir le président
des républicains
nicolas sarkozy
non nicolas moi je je je venais juste de
leur dire la seule chose que j'étais
vraiment venu leur dire c'était que les
régionales étaient un moment crucial sur
le chemin de l'alternance je pense que
tu leur diras mais avant de vous laisser
avec celui que vous êtes venu entendre
qu'il est le président des républicains
laissez moi juste vous dire une chose
les militants sont le sel de la terre
politique
vous êtes le sel de la terre politique
vous êtes engagé vous êtes là parce que
vous voulez défendre vos convictions
vous êtes là parce que vous savez que
c'est la mobilisation qui permettra de
faire voter et qui permettra
l'alternance vous êtes aujourd'hui les
ouvriers les ambassadeurs de
l'alternance vous voulez sauver votre
pays d'un gouvernement qui a tout raté
vous voulez sauver notre région vos
régions de président de région qui ont
échoué et c'est pour ça qu'à jo vous
êtes levés et que vous êtes dit je
deviens républicain alors on compte sur
vous on a besoin de vous et on vous
laisse avec notre président nicolas
sarkozy